I feel like we all started in our 20s, we're all growing up, we're literally growing up
together and here we find ourselves.
But the JCT, if you're not familiar with it, Joint Canadian Tandem Association, there's
one reason, one major reason, it exists to protect our industry.
So if you've been in the industry for a long time, you know that we've had our problems
today, that we haven't had those troubles in the last number.
So when all is quiet, that's wonderful, that means the JCT is working.
So being a part of the JTTA is just being a part of an association that regulates our industry.
So when the government looks at us, they can say, those guys are not the Wild Wild West.
These guys have a professional organization. They're based on professional standards that are solid.
And that's very important. So that's your number one reason.
It's us as a whole, us as a group, unified group, saying that we're professionals.
One of the cool things that we offer is a relationship with an insurance company.
So we have an insurance broker that we work with and they provide an excellent support system, program, and stability.
Good insurance is what I'm trying to say. What do you mean by good insurance?
So, yeah, good coverage. So the proper coverage is not always going to be the cheapest coverage, but it's going to be the coverage that you need if something terrible happens.
And that's really, really important. And as you heard Rachel say up here earlier, she's just had a flood in her salon, and fortunately for her, she's got the insurance.
Consumer marketing and public education, we do, we actually spend a lot of effort on Google advertising nationally,
where we direct consumers who are searching for PAN and other keywords directly back to our website,
which is PAN.ca, and we direct them to find only the JCCA member salon.
So, the salon that we know is our professional business.
And then, of course, having those professional standards and credibility.
Our JCCA board members that are here today.
So, first, I will bring up to the stage Ms. Susan Bracknell, our president,
Frank Finley, one man in the industry.
Okay, Rob is missing.
I'll take Rob.
Okay, you can take Rob.
Rob is making it here today.
I'll speak to the salon owners.
Ian is going to be here today.
So, Murph, come on up.
Murph is .
And we've got Steve Delroy.
And then last but not least,
both Nick Van Haren and Stubb McGowan.
Welcome to be a part of this board.
And they deserve a huge round of applause.
I'm up here talking to you and not Steve.
So this is a really big change.
There's been a change in management this season.
So for 2026, I'm taking over as the managing director.
And Steve is taking on, keeping with, keeping with his director of education responsibilities.
So that means that we've gone a separate road.
We're changing some systems.
We're making things, no big changes.
nothing's happening with your membership, everything is going to be a little bit
funky as I get the administration going. So I'm working on that. You can call me any time.
I'll put my contact information at the end. Our industry supporters obviously are hugely important,
and we're very lucky to have a number of supporters here in this room, including our
vendors. And this is a list of our 2025 supporters. I'm sorry I can't really see it from here. I'm
going to step down. First and foremost, having member salons is hugely important. We appreciate
everyone's support. As I mentioned, it's important that we're all unified in this.
Our Platinum sponsor, Uglux, for over $50,000. Both have always said that their investment
in the industry is priceless, and they really put their money where their mouth is. Our
They're the ones that take care of our insurance program, as well, every little dollar counts.
So, Sun Evolutions, J&W here in America, the Sun Club, Smart Team Canada, and Good Life Fitness for all of us.
I'm going to hand over the mic now to Liam and Doug.
Obviously, Leanne taking the reins in the JCK is a major step and a major change.
It means that Steve's retired from that role, and I'll tell you, the JCPH certainly wouldn't exist if it wasn't for Steve.
We started this in 2004, 2006. At the time, we were facing major national crisis.
We had four different associations across the country, and so Steve had the bright idea.
We brought them all together and put together a commitment, that's where my father made the commitment to be a sponsor, we still continue that obviously today.
But if it wasn't for the hard work and efforts of Steve bringing that group together, hence the name Joints.
And the word joint number I thought might be for weed, but it's not.
We are Canadians, but now we think that at this time we brought four different associations all together.
And under the leadership and stewardship under Steve, we certainly would be where we are today.
I would use the word unification. If one guy has brought the industry together in Canada, it would be this guy right here.
We're both pretty old now. I walked into the first badminton I ever walked into outside of Calgary when I was actually an employee.
and Steve was a franchisee back then, and it wasn't too late, soon after he left,
he was a franchisee, and then all of a sudden in 2006, we're in the Woodstock offices
talking about bringing the industry together, and Steve, again, was instrumental in that.
Road Warrior, man, we've been on some battles together.
Spent some time coast-to-coast from Ottawa to Victoria.
Legislature, lots of dinners with lots of people we would never have dinner with under normal circumstances.
including really nerdy scientists, but Steve has always been a constant gentleman and really,
really, I guess, presented our industry in a professional light. Now, that said, we are
old enough that I've shared a room with him and there was still smoking in the hotel.
Now, bless his heart, he opened the window and blew it out of your daughter one night.
But, Steve, thank you for what you've done. It's been an honour. Thank you for doing this.
It's important to note that Steve of course is not going anywhere, he remains the Executive
Director for SmartSafe Canada, so you can still reach out and talk to Steve.
He's not going anywhere.
But I appreciate all that he's done to hand the reins over to me and take a little step
back as we move forward with something new, a new challenge for me.
i'm excited after all these years it's kind of like whatever he's talking about it's like stay
invigorated right after maybe the industry after so many years it gives me a new challenge and
something to look forward to so i'm really excited and i don't know you yet i hope to
really personally by the end of the year so we are watching the time here today guys uh we read a
little wrong um as we do we felt like the information from both the song panel as well as
Mike Bloor was super great, super information to share.
Jenny is live streaming at five o'clock,
so we're gonna wrap this up at like quarter to 10 to.
Go next door, enjoy what Jenny might have
and can share with us, and then we'll kind of
roll back in here to finish off the day.
So, next up, up here in front of mine,
Jason, executive sales, global,
local, the guy, or
I'm going to discuss and talk to us on the program
and make you want to share.
And then we'll do the door prizes at the very, very end.
All right, well, good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you for hanging tight and hanging out with us.
Thank you to people like Sarah for putting on this great event.
I'm going to be just brief and short.
I have about 12 slides, so we're going to get just down to about one.
Now, make sure you've got time for Mike to come up here and share his wisdom with us today.
But most importantly, you know, the power of choice was the presentation I was going to go over.
But ultimately, choices drive every day for us, and they drive everything for you.
Whether we're 100% on your shelves or maybe just 25%,
I hope that we've made a connection or we can make a connection to grow that partnership
and continue to push this industry in the direction we're going.
We just had our annual award meeting just a few weeks ago, and it was all about this topic of evolution.
It's not a whole change in who we are, it's a change in our verbiage, it's a change in our appearance,
and we've evolved so much over the last 40 years together,
and New Sunshine is committed to continuing that path and pushing our brands to new heights
to help drive your business and support you with the products that you need.
need. With New Sunshine, there are six different brands, and with that being said, one thing
I just want to drive home is that you have choice, and it's all about what you pick to
go on your shelves. And I'm just going to jump really quick into this one. It starts
with your trust and your clear choices, and everything goes on your shelves. This is what
I want to drive home really quick. It's just simply, it's about the curation of what you
choose to have on your shelves. What you choose to have on your shelves, again, like
like Rachel said earlier,
basically took the words right out of my mouth.
It's carefully curated and selected for your business.
With that, like I said, we want to give 100%.
That's why we have our six brands.
And one thing I want to just message or say
is that our six brands, they're not just a brand.
It's not just a name.
They're pumping in money for logos and branding, et cetera.
We've invested in this industry and this business
by curating our brands at New Sunshine.
We acquired Designer Skin for a specific reason.
What their chemists, what they were doing as a business, were doing something unlike Australian gold.
Swedish Beauty, same thing.
California Tan.
We acquired the leading brands in this industry to have them under one roof,
but then to also maintain the heritage of what those brands were and what they are in this industry.
And that's what we're going to continue to honor as we continue forth another 40 years in this business.
But most importantly, like I said, you have a choice.
And we have a great option, too, with our programs.
With our program, it is 100% exclusivity,
but what I want you to not take away from that is exclusivity does not mean restraint.
You have options.
We have over 200 products to choose from with us,
and you have the best team here at Duvalux to educate you on all the products that we can choose from.
Like I said, we'd love to have 100%, but I'm happy to have 25 or to grow that war with you.
So between myself and the team at Duvalux and everyone back in Sunshine,
We're here and we're committed as we have been for the last four years to start this industry and this business.
I'm going to take the last minute really quick to just introduce someone that's my mentor, my role model, Marty Sperry.
He is our CEO.
What's very important about Marty that I want you guys to know is you don't get to see Marty or myself as much as like Jess or the other team members that are supporting the Ubilex team.
Marty's been with us for over 30 years.
And before moving into the CEO role in 2021, he was our CFO for many years before that.
And obviously at fun events like this, the drinking, the parties, the dinners, the CFO doesn't come to that.
But now as the CEO, he gets to come.
But what I just want to point out is that Marty started with us and no one knows his business and this industry and our company better than him.
So we're here to support you, as always, and we hope we can continue to build stronger partnerships, and we really appreciate you making the choice to be here, and the choice to carry our brains and your stories. Thank you.
Switch out.
That's my store price.
We're going to leave Mike to the end, just because I think he's got a lot of really interesting information to share with you guys, and I don't want to rush him.
We're going to go through the vendors to go over their program.
Next up, we're going to ask Gina up to the stage.
Everybody, a round of applause for Gina.
Can everybody hear me?
Alright, we on?
Okay, now we're on.
Well, what's shaking, baby?
What's going on?
So I was so excited to be here. I mean, it is very, very, very cold. But you know what? Each and every one of your smiles really brighten up my day.
And you know, you would think that I would be used to this growing up in northern Minnesota.
But I've been gone so long, and I don't know what happened, but a whirlwind happened, and y'all are really cold.
What we're going to do is we're going to give you a rundown of our Platinum Program.
So with our Platinum program, we understand that you have choices. There are so many fabulous
locations in this industry. My goodness, are we not in the best industry in the world?
Come on!
So one thing that we wanted to do though is because we keep educating you to have a loyalty
program, we too needed to have a loyalty program. So with our Platinum program, what it is,
is you carry 75% of our products, and you get a 10% cash back.
So how that will happen is you just purchase our products, sell our products,
and then we turn around and give you a 10% rebate.
And now you, the Lux, and myself will take care of that.
All you've got to do is keep doing what you've already done.
But as I said, it's 75%. You'll get 10% cash back.
But when you are part of the program, the really cool thing is you get me at,
can be pretty much readily available for you. Now I know I've given a lot of you guys my cards,
and guess what? Even if I gave you my card or you need a little bit of education and some training
from Gina, hey, I'm still here. I'm not going to say no. I'm not going to be like, no, I can't do
that. But I understand if you are black. Oh, I'm really going to take it to the next level.
And we want to be best friends, boo. So on top of the training, you're also going to get more
more support when it comes to wanting to do things
in the salon with promotions.
That's where you, Lil X, and I will work together
to make sure you have the tools that you need
to really help support the Sun Evolutions brand.
But again, this is a loyalty program,
just like you would do for your customers.
If they're loyalty, you want to make sure
that you're rewarding them.
And that's what we want to do as well.
But again, the distributors here,
sorry, the manufacturers here,
we really have you at their number one.
We are at your disposal, and if you need help, just come to us, let us know, and ask.
So, quick recap. Yes, we have a class rebate program. It's a loyalty program. 75% to 10% cash back.
You definitely get Gina as a bestie. You can email her and be like, alright.
We're thinking of doing a promotion and really want to focus on your best friend product, which is the Snoopy Blow Up.
Oh, absolutely. We'll go through some ideas and just help your staff be able to educate
why Gina loves it so much to help them be able to try it because once they try it, they're
going to love it. But now let's step into something a little extra. Let's talk about
the different things that you can do in your salon quick that's going to help increase
your money. So I'm going to be very short and simple, but I wanted to make sure that
but I gave you guys some ideas.
So you know how everybody does like Valentine's Day
and hey, come on, it's Valentine's Day.
But I'm a little salty,
because my husband normally like,
he doesn't do anything special for me for Valentine's Day.
And I think it's because I work at home,
so he's like, Gina, why do you need flowers?
It's not like you're gonna show Mom.
Because honestly, isn't that the only reason you want flowers?
I know it was definitely for me,
especially if I was in the office.
I would want to show Mom.
But there are so many different days of the month
that you guys can really vee-bop into fun things for your staff so like i put some of these on
here in march and if you do have questions about okay what did she mean by that go ahead and email
me also if you would like me to send you this list and i tell you what i start in january even though
we're almost done in january but it just helps you think outside of the box and i'm a big pusher of
of utilizing your loyalty programs
to be able to help support these different ideas and events.
So with that, I'm gonna go ahead and send her right on over
so you guys can have more.
But if you want more,
you know me, I will send her over
and you'll be ready to rock and roll.
Good job, Gina.
Thank you.
So you guys have heard a lot of the commotion
going on next door sometimes it kind of goes up in waves and raves i imagine that's probably
because these two young ladies are on the stage um uh this is gracie and and michaela from devoted
creations we asked me to wear a pink dress i said not yet rude rude next time she's not a team
player um so thank you guys so much for coming to the show i know a lot of you kind of made a
far little journey in the snow and all that so we appreciate you guys being here i promise we're
excited to be here and i've been so enjoying seeing a few familiar faces here as well
um but for those of you who don't know me i am michaela one of the sales trainers for the
print devoted i've been with the company about two years but i am uh familiar with working in
salons i'm originally from new jersey so i am a little used to the cold uh i did work at my salon
there then i moved to mississippi i was my manager at my salon there which we were a five-star
our dining salon, just like some of you are in this room, and we're going to kind of talk
about our five-star program, which means all I sold was devoted, all I used was devoted.
Now, I live in Florida, where it's also cold.
That's a reason to know we're online.
I'm like, I don't know, like, everything's just cold right now.
I'm like, it must be, like, the Antarctica or something.
But we're super excited to be here today and kind of share our program with you guys,
but I'll let Gracie go ahead and come take us first out.
Yeah.
Hello, everybody.
My name is Gracie.
I am our account executive over at Devoted, so I will train every now and again.
But for the majority of the time, I do a lot more of our kind of behind-the-scenes and back-end work.
So all of the nitty-gritty of our five-star program, I've had plenty of time to know and learn and love.
So we're very excited to be able to share that with you guys today.
I've been with Devoted for about eight months.
I did join this past summer, and actually, funnily enough, my very first event I ever got to go to
was the wonderful Uvalas brunch that was over the summer.
So a lot of familiar faces, some new faces.
But yeah, thank you guys so much for being here today, and we'll make it quick.
All right, so a couple highlights regarding our five-star program.
Our Canadian five-star program requires a no-contract agreement,
so you are not required to stay part of our program for any length of time.
Obviously, we want all of you to be a part of it, but it's either an in or you're out.
No contract, no time frame.
Another program benefit is that we have two different options for you guys,
which we'll kind of dive into.
We can tailor a little bit more so.
but you have one that is solely just your lotion and your eyewear cash back opportunities.
And then on the flip side, you have one that also kind of ties in some different advertising opportunities as well
to just optimize and kind of guarantee more cash back into your guys' pockets for purchases you are already making.
We have a very super easy social media cash back opportunity that Mikayla will talk a little bit more about in a couple slides.
And then another big thing is we do not ask for full exclusively.
I know that there are definitely benefits on both sides of the spectrum and you may be wondering why we do not require that.
The biggest reason is that we never ever want you guys to lose customers or have your sales waver one way or another because you're not able to carry another manufacturer's products.
So the beauty of this is we have a certain percentage that we'll discuss that we ask that you have exclusively DC on your shelves.
And then that other smaller percentage, you are free to carry any other manufacturers and other products to keep your customers, whether current or not, happy and guaranteed to continue coming back to your salon because you aren't required to carry one or the other.
And then in terms of the actual program dates, we do kind of do like a full rebate period.
So that is going to run every single year starting on November 1st and dating all the way to October 31st.
And that time at the end of the year, we do get a full report from the wonderful Google Express,
and then they kind of do a lot of the nitty-gritty work for us.
They send it over to us, and then we make sure that from those dates and within the program,
any single DC purchase that you have made, you are getting that full cashback opportunity.
So your first program option is exclusively just about emotions.
We're not going to talk about anything social media or advertising related yet,
but that 10% cash back option, like we said, we only require that 75% of your products
are devoted creations. This is going to include not only your lotions, but also your packets
as well as any of your eyewear. All of your orders are going to be submitted through Ubulux
so that is a requirement. You cannot accept any other orders or kind of shipments that's
been taken care of through another distribution realm. It does have to go through Ubulux and
And the beauty of it is that your Ufalex reps are so on top of things that they are keeping you running a report throughout the year to make sure that as soon as we get this report, you are not having to do any of the math or any of the nitty-gritty work.
We have that sent over, and we kind of do that quality assurance check to make sure that you're getting every single cent back that you're going to send.
The only qualification aside from that 75% eligibility is going to be that you spend a minimum of $100 per qualified.
That can honestly, you guys, be like $2.
if even, sometimes it's even more.
So, very easy to qualify,
and it's just getting money back on purchases
that you really already should be making for your sales.
Any questions?
All right, simple enough, right?
All right, all right.
The next option that you guys have for your program
is gonna be your 17% cashback,
and this is gonna be through your purchases and advertising.
So kind of the same situation
where you would want to have 75% of your shelves
at least be to go to Creations
and already our family of brands.
And like I said, 75%, but the more they fill in your shelves, obviously the more money
you're going to get back.
Just like Gracie said, we don't ask for full exclusivity because we don't want you guys
to lose customers before like, say, one bottle.
We do not want that to happen.
We want you guys and your customers to be satisfied.
But for this portion, you do have to qualify under the 10%, which is the first portion,
having at least 75% of your lotions, purchases, and your eyewear being devoted to creation
We're a family brand, so you have to qualify for that portion as well.
And then we do ask that any advertisement, anything that you guys do within social media,
even if you create T-shirts or anything like that, you do include our logo.
Super, super easy.
I mean, you guys can literally reshare a story post, something literally like that.
We look at all of this stuff throughout our social channels.
And then if you guys tag us in everything, we can see them.
And I always encourage utilizing your social media even more than probably what you guys already are.
And I know Hubelux does a really great job of promoting things on their social media as well.
Because I was kind of listening in on the owner's panel earlier.
Everybody was just talking about how important social media is, right?
That is where your customers are going. That's where they're looking.
I am in that age group where I don't call a place to see if they're open when it's snowing outside.
I check their Instagram, their Facebook.
So post, hey, we're closed for a few hours, or delayed opening for snow, put our logo on it, and it's going to go towards that cashback opportunity, and it's super simple.
We also have so many marketing outlets that we create and make our social media teammates for you guys to use, where you can screenshot, screen share, literally repost on your social channels, so that you guys don't have to do anything.
We don't want this to be like another kind of job on top of your already super busy jobs and lives.
We want this to be super easy because you guys are the reason how the reason why to go to creations goes around, right?
This is one big family effort between us you loves and you guys so we can't go on this you guys grow
So we all kind of benefit from this so that's where we you know
Make these different types of marketing tools so that you guys can utilize them within your social channels to make it a lot easier
So you can get this
75 17%
We do ask for a little bit of exclusivity here
just because we do want to see a lot of our brand on your social channels, but I
will say we're a little busy. But we just ask that a lot of your Instagram accounts
like all of your shops, right? So any questions on this portion? Then our selfie glow
summits. So this is going to be completely separate. It's calculated completely
separate, separate, words are hard today, from your initial devoted creations cashback. So
retail products. You do have to spend $250 within retail. Selfie Go retail products is
anything like your Rose All Spray, your Selfie Sun Kiss Drops, your amazing, wonderful Tana
River, your Selfie Double Bubble, anything like that that you can have as a retail where
your customers can buy. Then, you can get 10% cash back on all of your solutions. This,
obviously, you do not have to have UV. You can also use just a strictly sunless salon
to also participate in this portion of our five-star program.
And I think that's all we have for you guys, but I do have a quick question.
Who is a part of our event burger?
Yay! Love it.
You guys can also earn, you know, opportunities to have trainings.
We can do all kinds of things like that.
That is literally my job.
I come to Canada pretty often.
I know I was with our Pimpton family not that long ago and did some trainings for them.
So that's something we can always kind of work into something
if that's something you're interested in for your staff.
And then we also do events.
So you guys can reach out to your you belongs reps
We can do custom event kits for you guys so that you guys can have these awesome wonderful events to make your salons more successful
So I think that's all I have like I said, thank you guys for coming. We appreciate you guys being here
Come stop by and see the products if you haven't already, but thank you
So as I said, JWoww is live streaming at 5 o'clock
So we're going to pack this up at 4.50 and head next door to watch JWoww, and then Mike has graciously
allowed us to put him after that. So I encourage you, because Mike and his numbers are second down,
I certainly encourage you to come back and do that portion of it.
Leading up until now, I want to introduce a few friends of mine.
This guy has been in the cave industry actually not all that long, but his history of piracy has certainly added a lot of value
in what he's done, and it's acknowledged worldwide as far as what the Canadian Ministry is doing.
It's just awesome. I learned every day from Charles. So, big round of applause for Charles.
Thank you, Nick. So, I made a presentation way too long for the time I have, so I'm going to focus on a couple slides.
I just wanted to sort of thank you, Alexa, for being here.
Those events are so important for the industry we learn, we learn as manufacturers, hopefully we can learn and we can keep doing that to become smaller and better in the industry.
So, I just wanted to start really quickly with this slide that just talks about JK, which is an airline brand as well as a development system brand, a selling brand.
A little bit about our company value, because I think it's very important to explain and show you guys why we're here and why we do the things we do.
So, first of all, the equipment itself, as a matter of fact, this is our expertise, we try to stick to it, and to support our industry.
But also, and that's very important, almost 100 years old company, it's going to be next year, but this is where I can copy-paste the presentation for next year.
You don't become a 100-year-old company without really caring about why you do things, what you do it for, etc.
And that just really dictates everything we do and how we support the industry.
We're a firm supplier. We're fully integrated with the market. That comes with market and technology research.
You know this, JK is Wealth System and Airline. All of you know Airline. All of you probably should have an airline in 10, 10 years long.
But we also incorporated Wealth System. Wealth System is a wellness brand. This is what we're talking about in the first part.
The theme of this event is 10 years wellness. We are wellness. This is very much a company value and what we believe in.
This is what has been successful for the past 20-30 years with the WellSystem brand and we can keep it this way.
Expert and consultant, we listen, we learn and we share.
Someone in the panel was talking about changing the way your staff is selling the product.
They've become influencers.
We believe that we should not sell you a piece of equipment, we should help you and consult for your business.
because your success is going to be our success, that's our mission, ethical, your success is our success.
It doesn't matter if we sell you today, what matters is can we help your business to be successful in every aspect we can
and that's really our company value and that's the way we see the relationship and this is how we work with parts of LinkedIn.
So I will not go over selling but I will just say that.
We have some software without going into details. Why? Because in order to take the emotion out of some decision, we need to look at that.
And I'm a data person. I work with data person as well. And Mike and I, when we talk, we just talk about what's really showing in the numbers.
We believe this is the essence of every business decision is looking at data.
That is why our company invested in a software company that POS represents.
And one thing I would say, it's not selling.
Anyone else does.
Make sure you operate and make business decisions with a powerful software that can share.
What I wanted to talk today about and spend most of the time I have available on stage here is
a revelation that comes from the training industry.
You guys have heard there's a full element of it that comes to market.
This is not just new, fancy, it's a real change in the industry.
It gives us as a manufacturer a charity to present a completely different way to tan
and to present the tanning industry as a charity to bridge tanning and wellness.
And I will give you a little more about this.
Yes. So what we have developed is a technology called Spectre.
And for anybody who owns a piece of very bad equipment,
you're probably going to be upset because it's going to be very old
and it can sell you a piece of equipment too long.
But this is how we design a piece of equipment.
We design it to last, to be reliable for your business.
This is absolutely essential because if the bed goes down
or if the bed breaks after five years and you have to purchase another one,
your business is at risk and you can't afford that.
But this is really with this value in mind that we have spent too long,
but the necessary amount of time to develop our technology.
It's brand new, it changes everything.
There's a ton of challenges that come with the technology
and we wanted to make sure that when we put an equipment in your salon
that we're very confident in the reliability of the technology,
the reliability of the machine,
but also the tanning results and the tanning experience for the next year.
There's a lot of advantage when it comes to LED technology and that's really where the interesting piece of
bridging tanning and wellness comes into play. With the LED technology you can control the ratio between UVA and UVB
so you can just really come up with a balance that is as close as the natural sunlight
while still getting the natural tanning experience, the natural sun experience.
When before with the light technology, you have little control over it.
You have like the filter on your gloves, the filter in the sun, UV and UVB,
and you've got what you've got. It can be more powerful. It's powerful.
LED allows to really balance this out and play this out.
So we spend a lot of time with tanning every skin type in Germany for three, four years
and making tests at what is the perfect ratio to make it as gentle and as best hand as possible,
LED technology allows to do that. There's also a very cool factor for where we're trying the
elements or solid elements, this is the minority, maybe I shouldn't start with that, is the color
that's coming over there. If you talk about the UV spectrum, light spectrum is invisible to the eye.
UV light spectrum is outside of the visible light spectrum.
It's just before the light.
So if we have a perfect LED with a perfect UV spectrum, you don't see anything.
So if we just create an LED attending unit and you turn it on, you will see nothing.
So for the first time, and we saw this in our chair,
for the first time, we had a white canvas to design what the light or the visual experience
And so we decided to get as close as possible to a natural tanning experience, to make it
wellness, to make it relaxing, to make it feel like a day at the beach.
And so we played with the colors.
We know red is amazing.
Red light is amazing for tanning.
Red light is powering your cells to perform better, to repair itself.
And so when your cells receive UV, they create melanin.
If you boost them with red light, you improve the tanning results.
longer-lasting tan, etc. So red light was a must to include in the light. But we also
look at what else can we bring into this white canvas to make a great experience.
And so we decided that green was the best way. Because if you go back to kindergarten, when you mix red and green, you've got yellow, and the sun at the end of the beach is yellow, and you figure that if you mix that properly, it's going to give that amazing experience.
Green is also a known color to offer relaxation.
If you feel stressed, depressed,
doctors could tell you,
chromotherapy will tell you,
look at the green forest
and the birds cooking and everything
and that's just going to naturally relax you.
Color acts on it.
I think if one industry can believe
in the power of light,
is this industry,
and even if it seems a little abstract sometimes,
that our brain is relaxing, is that true?
Life has an effect on us, on our body,
and on our mind as well,
and so we mix those two light spectrums
to create a very natural and well-established
tending, and that's what I'm talking about,
this opportunity that Ellen's offered us,
to bridge tending and wellness.
Talking about the technology and the reliability,
ability to go from the experience to the actual technology. I say we spend a lot of time to
work on our technologies because we identify that LED is extremely sensitive and when you
are talking about a laser, about a light spectrum, your strength gets very consistent. A light
bulb is going to have a very long hole of confusion, so you have a long range of light
But it is much narrower. So when coming with the output, we want to make sure it's consistent,
because we want to make sure the tending experience continually is equivalent for the lifetime of the unit.
But it's also perfect for the perfect tending results.
And we don't want this to be out of so many things that are into play with the LED.
It's a very sensitive technology.
It's ESD, it's electrostatic discharge. If you have too much electrostatic, it could affect the LED, it could change the output, it could be dramatic if it's just affecting the LED too much.
So we wanted to make sure that the unit is looming perfectly in the best, perfectly sealed environment.
It needs to be very clean. We know that TENIX can be dirty with the dust and the lotion and everything.
So we have encapsulated every LED separately. We have a sensor on each LED to make sure they are working, to make sure they control the output, to make sure they control the temperature.
They are connected to an EPF filter, and so this is a closed cycle. So when you hit an element, technically, you cannot access the LED.
It's on a closed circle, so it's consistent, it's reliable, and you have the same 10-week
experience for maybe 20,000 hours.
We tested for that for more than 20,000 hours in the factory, the output, and that's longer
than that.
We just added a valuation of 10% after 20,000 hours, and that's why we say we'll stay consistent
for that time.
We've put a lot of effort to make sure that we get you a technology that's very reliable.
And I want to talk a little bit about the price here.
But you guys know new technology and technology like this with all its advantages comes at a price.
And there's a lot of advantage to the price you pay for new technology and what it does.
Gary, do you want to talk a little bit about this?
So you don't hear about me all the time. Gary, who is actually the director of Sunlink,
happened to own Elegant from one of his stores, and he's a new guy for me.
And so he did the cost analysis, and I figured he would be a better person than me.
Being the director of Sunlink, I've also got four stores in New Jersey, four tanning salons.
I guess like a typical business owner I'm on budget right I like to have nice
new things but there's not always enough money to purchase all the new spa equipment and all the new updated planning equipment.
Obviously when I saw the elements I got excited I wanted this bed but of course it's super expensive.
But the part that I like about it being all LED technology is one the electricity is much cheaper.
So I replaced my open sun 1050, which was a super popular, you know, tanning bed for me as well as my customers, but it was 20 years old.
The bed wasn't looking new anymore, and even though it was tan gray, parts were breaking, repairs were expensive.
On the flip side of the open sun 1050, it's the most electric consumption of all my units, and it also has the most frequent, most expensive lamp changes.
My lamp changes probably cost me U.S. dollars, I would say between lamps and labor, close to $2,000.
In New Jersey, we're lucky enough to have super expensive electricity, so I pay 35 cents per kilowatt hour.
And again, so with the elements having 20,000 hours before a lamp change, the 20,000 hours are going to outlast the equipment.
So basically I've got a bed now that I've had for six weeks that is never going to be a lamp change.
Besides that, the amount of sale runs around 20 amps give or take. It's 70 amps for an open sun.
So just the electricity and the lamp savings I'm estimating is going to save me around $1,000 to $1,500 a month.
I like to finance my equipment and that $1,000 to $1,500 is just short of what my lease payment is.
So me, as a business owner, on a budget, I mean obviously that's on my highest level.
I don't have any concern about customers panning into that part of it.
My concern always is how am I going to pay for it, right?
Because I'm on all these nice new things, but it's not, you know, on a limited budget.
And having those cost savings is just an easy way that I can have nice new things.
And compared to a traditional canning bed, again, through less electricity and through those lamp changes,
I'm able to save a lot of money and have this nice new bed that doesn't cost me the same, you know, as what other homes cost.
The other part that I like about it is, again, I don't want to say like a typical tanning salon because there's a lot of operators here that are better than me,
but the one problem that I have is I'm only having four stores and not a limited budget.
I don't have a full maintenance team, right? I have to contact my local distributor.
I got a schedule for them to come out, and what happens is I want to change my open sun
hours at maybe 400 or 450, right?
So I get a notification at that point, but I'm busy.
I forget about it.
And what ends up happening is my lamps get changed out at $600.
And the beauty is the lamps still light up, right?
But the customer is not getting a good experience.
On an open sun, I would say maybe for the first 75 to 100 hours on raining lamps, it's
hot, it's great, the tan's great.
And then the tan starts to go down as the hours go up on the lamps and by 600 hours usually I've got one lamp out
And I don't think it's tanning anywhere near you know as good as it should so back to the elements because it lasts 20,000 hours
No lamp changes every single session is always just like having brand new lamps and with my open sun
Let's say 70% of those sessions were not a great experience
So I'm trying so hard to keep my customers and meanwhile
But I can't keep up on my equipment enough to keep those random lamps in there all the time.
So for me, I like the fact that the elements, I put it in, I turn it on, and for the next 10-15 years, I don't have to worry about it.
It's always giving a great tan, and it's important to me.
You said one thing the other day too that was very interesting, what you were saying was
it's not just the money you save with the session because of the element.
It's also the other session that the element takes from other tending beds, because you
want this bed to be used and it's proper, it's nice, and people tending the elements
instead of another tending bed, that between Vitality or P9 or other equipment, the energy
consumption, the length change, the fact between any other bed and a full LED bed, if they
were using the LED bed, you're not using lamps on another piece of equipment.
It's less energy, it's less length changes than us.
So the savings are exponential to how much people are using the elements.
So that was a good output, you know, for me.
Do we have one more time?
Yeah, I think that's about it.
Well, I mean, I have way too much slides for you.
If you guys have any questions on the value bet, is there any questions that I can answer for the elements?
This is the best question I could expect and I should have actually called, so thank you so much for your question.
This is our biggest up your level since we released the update.
It's hot, it's comfortable, it's hot, but it's not as hot as a 10 feet.
We know what heat does, heat, mature skin aging, skin dryness, etc.
There's also two ways to get a tanning unit hot.
It's either a lot of UVA output or less air conditioning.
And too much UVA is not good, not enough air conditioning reduces the life expectations of the tanning unit.
So heat is our enemy.
Now we also know that to have a successful experience with your customer developing for heat, you need to have heat enough.
And that was very big part of when we designed the UVA heat.
We want to make it hot, but as less as necessary as possible, because we want to make sure we get as close as possible to wellness.
If you spend all this money and all this time taking wellness customers to your salon to create new customers, you won't damage the tent.
Because this is where you're going to sell lotion, and this is where you're going to maximize your revenue per square footage.
So, we want to still offer the tenors a warm experience, we want to make it not too hot, so it's capturing one's customers as well, and that's a complex equation.
So, I'm not gonna lie, it's a lot of education for us, from our company, and we talked a lot to salon owners, and the most difficult part is those salon owners used to talk to their staff,
because their staff gets a customer walking in the door and says I want the hottest bed
you've got because they believe it's the best way. So the salon staff needs to understand
and educate and change people's mind to as hot as possible is the best way to tend and
give more education to the occupant petition. So I guess unfortunately there's a lot of
education to do with our customers. The new technology allows to tend really good without
without as much heat on us to take our part into the people around us.
I just keep causing more worries about that when you go skiing by the 35
and you're not home. Absolutely.
You're the perfect example here. I'm sure if you just get outside
in the sunny and it's snowing, you're probably going to tend better
just because that's how it works.
It will take time and education. Heat is not
doesn't mean tanning, and a lot of the time, when you get out of a very hot bed and you
dye the gray colors, it is not pigmentation, it is heat, because the tanning and the delineation,
delineation of the surface, it doesn't happen in 10 minutes, it happens in multiple hours.
So their feeling of instant regurgitation is also why they like the tanning experience,
but it's not true, and you give them that this is really good for them.
Is there having that conversation now before I leave?
Because obviously this is where I'm going to hold to this.
Should we start having a conversation with the facility and the nephrologist?
Yes, I think that the sooner you have it, the better, because you won't take time.
There's also a lot of technology out there, the new thing that only happens with the technology in the facial.
The facial area was high-pressure length, which is the most energy consumption, but also the most
the creation of heat in the tanning unit that goes right up to your face.
It will be one of the most sensitive parts of your body too.
So, all the airline decided four years ago that every tanning unit that we have that has facial
will be LED facial.
And we've faced a lot of kickbacks in the industry.
I want to get hot, I want to get a tan, I want to sit in a car, it took a lot of effort from us to be capable, it started to be understood, because the tanning results are still here and the experience is better, but without going for L&D and development, you have to go to out there and tell the other unit that already offer less experience, with us better than the tan, so educate as soon as possible, as you should.
I will say that the element is here in Titanic, but it's also in Vostok.
And so, I'm assuming most of us here are the west coast people, has the opportunity to be able to drive.
And so, whether it's the element you want to come and use, the well system you want to come and, you know, take a half hour nap, we encourage it.
Cocoon, as well as all the other spray and other technologies we have.
Please, come to the office, bring a little spa day, bring a couple of your managers, your staff, we certainly encourage it.
So, we're going to head next door.
Afterwards, we're going to come back here.
We're going to do door prizes and listen to Mike.
Your employees are done.
They're wrapped up.
We're wrapping up right now.
They're allowed to hang out at the table on the floor,
talk to the local manufacturers,
talk to whomever they would like to,
and then we'll wrap up here.
Please, everybody, let's work our way next door.
And your phone on the airplane or something, let's talk about this when we get home.
It's really important.